can i have a pen
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the
college readout of the meeting which
took place
this morning wednesday 23rd of september
i will give the floor to vice president
sukinas who will do the college readout
and after that he will present together
with commissioner johansson the pact on
migration and
asylum which was discussed this morning
by the college
vice president
thank you thank you dana welcome
let me indeed start with the rest of the
college agenda before
taking you into the new pact and
migration and asylum
today the college discussed the upcoming
action plans on the capital markets
union and the customs union
and the new ambitious package on digital
finance
developing our capital markets and
ensuring access to market financing will
be essential in helping europe recover
from the crisis and this action plan
precisely shows the way out
the digital finance package will boost
eu competitiveness and innovation in the
financial sector
it will give consumers more choice and
opportunities in the financial services
and modern payments my colleague valdis
dombrovskis
will hold the press conference on this
package tomorrow
after midday and finally the new customs
union action plan will make eu customs
smarter
more innovative and more efficient and
it will help protect the eu revenues and
the security health and prosperity
of our citizens and businesses and
our colleague commissioner paolo
gentiloni will
present this package to you on monday
on other business uh the commission has
also
decided to create a task force
to resolve uh and help
alleviate the emergency situation on
lesvos following the fires at the moria
camp
this new task force will implement a
joint pilot with the greek authorities
for new reception facilities and in line
with the framework proposed today
in the new pact which we will present to
you in a minute
this task force will help ensure that
migration is managed in an effective way
including adequate living conditions
more certainty
faster procedures and more balanced
responsibility
and solidarity sharing the task force
will be based in dg home
and will operate under the
responsibility of
the commissioner commissioner johansson
but of course this is the result
of a series of consultations and
discussions that president vanderlian
herself
together with prime minister mitsodakis
and chancellor america
had the opportunity to have these last
days
ah and uh the person the commission
official who will lead
this uh task force sorry uh
sorry not to do with the task force but
we have an appointment in dg home that i
also need to announce which is not
related to the task force
is we have a new deputy director general
indige home
and this is our austrian colleague
johannes luchner
congratulations to him finally before we
go to the pact
uh on the occasion of the international
day of sign languages i'm happy to
announce that today's press conference
will also be interpreted
into international sign language and we
will strive to interpret
all weekly college readouts into
sign language in the future so stay
tuned let me now move quickly
to the main policy file
of today's agenda the new
pact on migration and asylum this is an
important moment
you know that this is one of the most
emblematic flagship initiatives of the
vanderlian college
you know that this has been long time in
the making
at the time for action is now
the problems we see on migration on
moria
elsewhere are not because of europe
but that precisely because they simply
symbolize the cost of non-europe
so the time for action is now and
we are presenting today together with a
commissioner
a compromise a landing zone
able to bring about an agreement
you have seen and you know well that
this is not something that we have
stopped bilaterally here at the berlin
mall but this is the result
of extensive consultations and listening
exercises we traveled with the
commissioner
to all eu capitals we met all ministers
heads of state and government we spent
weeks at the european parliament and we
feel
that what we are presenting today
crystallizes all the input we received
in this
long consultation process
in migration no member state
has the same way of experiencing the
phenomenon
there are different angles there are
different priorities there are different
voices there are different views there
is different geography
each of our member states faces
different and unique challenges
and i would also say that no one's
concerns
are more legitimate more legitimate than
the others
they all deserve to be recognized
acknowledged
and addressed and that's precisely what
we're doing today
we have also learned the lessons of 2016
the wounds of 2016 and the failure of
the european union to bring up
to to establish to foster an agreement
then
is uh also very present with us that's
why we need to start
with everyone on board and everyone
around the table as the president said
minutes ago solidarity
and responsibility are the two pillars
that guide this
package and in europe solidarity
and responsibility should never be
a binary choice otherwise
if we allow this to become a binary
choice
it would be like this spielberg movie
back to the future
while you travel to the future only to
encounter the problems of the past
so the essence of the new package
and i think the easiest way to describe
it
is like a house with three floors
the first floor is a very strong
external dimension
centered around strengthened
partnerships with countries of origin
and transit
the second is a robust management of our
external borders and the third is
firm fair internal rules of solidarity
so that those who are under pressure can
have the certainty
that the rest of the of the of the
family
can uh give them a hand very quickly to
take you through the three
main floors and then the commissioner
will provide more detail
on each of them i'm starting with the
external dimension
and the relations with countries of
origin and transit
europe needs neighbors
partners in the world to manage
migration flaws
and the change of paradigm we're
presenting today
will mean that we will work upstream
with all our partners to make sure that
this is the case
since 2015 we have dedicated over 9
billion euros to support refugees and
migrants
outside the eu providing lying life
serving assistance
to millions of vulnerable people
supporting host communities and
international organizations
what we will be doing with countries of
origin
and transit will have a double objective
first
to help them help their people so that
they can have a better life
with more opportunities in their
countries instead of putting their lives
in the hands of the smugglers
in the mediterranean or the engine and
second
we want to do more for the countries
themselves
so that we can help them break
the business model of the smugglers help
them establish
better effective mortar management
asylum and reception systems
returns and readmissions and with a pact
you will see that we are stepping up
cooperation in all these areas
and in our relations with third
countries this
will be based on win-win partnerships
we will support these partnerships in a
way that makes sense for both these
countries and ourselves
and this will include the strategic
flexible policy driven funding
from the eu and as you know in our
proposals for the neighborhood
development international cooperation
instrument
which comes with the unpronounceable
abbreviations
and the key we already have
reserved over 70 billion euros including
a 10
target for migration related action
on the second floor the robust
management of the external borders
there will be new and mandatory
screening at all borders
of all arrivals under the new system
currently the only obligation is for a
member state to take the fingerprints of
someone who arrives irregularly
and simply registers under the new pact
all arrivals will be subject to a
thorough security health and identity
check
and this will allow for immediately
directing people immediately to the
right procedure
in a second stage all those unlikely to
get
asylum will have to go because they come
from countries with a low recognition
rate
they will have to go through mandatory
fast-track border procedures
with streamlined processes for dealing
quickly with asylum claims
and efficiently processing returns
this will create a seamless procedure at
our external border
which ensures people are quickly guided
to the right procedure
and avoids black holes and bottlenecks
like the ones we're having in the
current system
or may i say in the current non-system
and this will be of course the emphasis
on borders will be
complemented by a new european ecosystem
geared towards effective returns
with a new eu coordination on returns
in dg home under commissioner johansson
and frontex
playing a role a much more operational
law
becoming an operational arm on border
management
and as we prove the neverows the
beginning of march
europe can now effectively
ensure border management finally on the
third
floor of our theoretical house we find
you will find firm but fair
internal rules and solidarity
you know the president said it nicely
she said
we are not discussing whether we will
have solidarity
but how the solidarity will provide it
so we are have devised the system of
permanent effective
constant solidarity that would give at
all times
the assurance that the member state that
is
under a specific type of situation can
obtain
the the level of help that needs from
the system
so this strong solidarity mechanism will
of course not ignore the red lines
but we have looked for a solution
between
the red lines and we have done so
by introducing a new concept which we
call
return sponsorship that allow
to do something that is new and
let me take a minute to to explain
this is a concept that seeks to balance
out
competing interests we know that all
member states will never accept
mandatory relocation that's one thing
we know already at the same time
relocation and not only sending help
or border guards is what really
alleviates pressure
from member states facing high
numbers of arrivals so with this return
sponsorship
we have provided we are providing
a viable alternative to ensure that
even if they are not relocated the same
numbers
can be catered for and the member state
under pressure
we can ask for the member states willing
to perform this return sponsorship
help and that would take the system
into some sort of balance and
equilibrium and sponsoring member states
of course will be able to focus on
nationalities
where they see a better chance of
completing returns
and the system will always allow
for this interdependence between an
alternative to relocation and effective
support
and depending on the level of pressure
and the ability of our systems to cope
we are confident that we will at all
times
provide this assurance of permanent
constant
effective solidarity and
the solidarity situation will be
structured along three work streams
three typologies of solidarity
depending on the situation that the
member state finds itself
can activate the relevant procedures and
we have
identified and we're proposing three
work streams
for this a crisis situation
a search and rescue situation and a
situation of pressure
or risk of pressure for each of these
three strands
we will have specific criteria for
effective and permanent solidarity
we are not stopping there we do not
forget that there are a number of
elements that we will continue to
prepare
and will come out at the later second
stage
first schengen we do not forget that
this is the most
important most crucial of the topics
and we will present next year a strategy
for the future of schengen
and legal migration something that we
want to be very ambitious on
but which deserves its own moment its
own narrative
divorced from the discussions on
irregular migration
this is why today we have launched a
public consultation to gather views on
this topic
and proposals will follow next year
let me conclude this is a new system
it's a new fresh beginning it is a
connected
whole everything connects to everything
else
and we are confident that this new
european framework
can allow for a rational proper
logical management of migration policy
in europe
we have withdrawn and drawn a line under
the former dublin system
it was symbolic of an era
that is different dublin was meant
for very few asylum seekers fleeing
dictatorship from southern europe
dublin was not meant to face up
the challenges of global migration
europe is facing today
and will continue to face in the future
let me finish with saying that
we are very proud of the european union
we are the biggest and the better
regulated market in the world we have
the second
global currency we have universal
systems
of education of health we have no death
penalty
we take care of our elderly we have a
fantastic recovery plan
based on a new novel approach
it's unthinkable that this europe in
2020
still does not have a proper
single cohesive
migration and asylum policy we hope that
today is the beginning of a process
that will take us there thank you very
much vice president
commissioner please the floor is yours
thank you very much
migration has defined our societies for
centuries
enriched our cultures and shape our
lives
so said president van der lyon in her
state of the union speech
and i think this is very crucial
migration is
normal migration has always been here
migration will always be here
sometimes in the debate we try to make a
link between migration and crisis
but most of the migrants that come to
european union come here legally
last year 2.4 million migrants
got a resident permit in european union
most of them because they fell in love
with the eu citizen and they marry
but also for other family reasons to
work here
to study here and also some that got
asylum
last year one around one million left
european union and that means that we
have an extra
one one and a half million people coming
to the european union every year
and we need them because we're an aging
society
and many of those are being european
citizens
last year almost 700 000 new european
citizens
citizenship were issued so this works
quite well i should say and we need
migration
but on the headlines in the news is of
always what's not
work so well and that is the situation
with the irregular arrivals
last year we had 140 000 irregular
arrivals to the european union and this
is really what we are addressing now
in our proposal to manage in a much
better way
and i think that uh when we are
discussing the proposal that we now have
put on the table
i understand that a lot of people still
are in the mood of the situation in 2015
but we are not there in 2015
we had 1.8 million irregular arrivals to
the european union
and almost all of them were refugees
as i said last year 140 000 irregular
irregular arrivals and a minority of
them
one-third were refugees the others
are not refugees and they will have a
negative asylum decision
and a return decision and that shows
also what we need to
address better is the effectiveness
on returns and readmission to the
countries of origin
what we need to do is to move away with
from few
we need fewer irregular arrivals
and instead have more regular arrivals
that's why we have to focus on legal
pathways
both for migrants to come to contribute
to our economy
and for refugees that need international
protection
and i'm very proud that the european
union are doing so much when it comes to
resettlement
of refugees and we are in also now
proposal
having a proposal to step up on that
with a new community-sponsored
resettlement
to be able to have fewer irregular
arrivals we need to
fight the human smugglers these are well
organized criminal
networks that are earning a lot of money
by smuggling people
into the european union and at the same
time a lot of people have to risk their
lives
this is not how it should be done and
that's as margaritis just pointed out
the importance
of working very close together with
third countries with our partner
countries
to fight the smuggling together
we also need to focus more on returns
and that's you can see in our package
today there's a lot of new initiatives
when it comes to be
more effective on returns and i'm coming
back to that
one of the importance is of course to
have good readmission agreements with
third countries
and that's gonna be a prioritizing
they're gonna be prioritized
i will go through uh how we should
address
the problems and the challenges that we
are facing and as margaritis rightly
said we had to have a lot of dialogues
with member states with parliament with
other stakeholders
to find just to listen where are the
shortcomings
without a common european migration and
asylum system
and these we are addressing in our pro
our proposal to be able to manage
migration better
of course it's fundamental to defend
the right to apply for asylum and that
means that it's also fundamental how we
protect our borders that we do it in a
way that is in compliance with the
geneva convention and the right to apply
for asylum
we will propose a new monitoring and
independent monetary mechanism
for all member states to implement and
in guidance with their
european agency for fundamental rights
to make sure
that they are not being pushbacks at the
borders
when any regular arrivals come to the
european union there will be a mandatory
screening process
this will take maximum five days there
you will do the registration of course
into the euroduck
and in your duck we'll have much more
information with our new proposal than
in the current one
you can find out also whether this
person has been in europe before for
example and already have a decision
maybe
there will also be security checks
health checks
and a decision on which country is
responsible for this application
and which kind of procedure so this
person go through if this uh
asylum applicants have a connection to
another member states
state like having a sibling there have
been working there have studying there
then the other member state is
responsible for the application
and to process that if the person has
coming from a country with a very low
recognition rate
under 20 percent and it's not
a family with small children it's not an
unaccompanied
minor it's not a person with medical
needs
then this person should go to a border
proceed procedure
and this border procedure has the same
rights for the person to have
his or her application processed in a
proper and fair way
but it has to be done very quickly and
i think that many of those will have a
negative decision
but not all of them some will have a
positive and then of course
they have the asylum in the country why
do we do this
we do this because it will make it
easier for voluntary returns
i think when a person has been living in
a country for years
having relations falling in love then
it's much more difficult both for the
individual
and for the authorities to do the return
return
to the country of origin it's important
that we can have this
decision of returns very quickly in 12
weeks and then also be able to do the
returns
this is also an important message that
you will be returned
if you are coming to european union and
do not have the right to stay
and i think this is what the european
citizens ask from us
they i think they say well we are ready
to welcome those in need of
international protection
we are ready to welcome those that have
the legal right to work or study in
our union but those do not have the
legal right to stay
they have to go back and this is what we
are really focusing on
in our proposal if
as margarita said it's also important
that we have a solidarity mechanism
of course all member states have to deal
with migration because migration is a
normal thing
but there could be a situation where the
migration
pressure is high or risk of being high
and then there is a possibility to
activate the solidarity mechanism
and as president from the line just said
a few
minutes ago solidarity is not optional
everybody has to contribute to the
solidarity
but there are some possibilities to
choose in what way
to show your solidarity the two main
ways to show solidarity is either via
relocation
of those probably in need of
international protection
or with the new return sponsorship
where member states are helping each
other to actually do
the returns of those not eligible to
stay
and make sure that they will be
reintegrated in the country
of origin this uh re
this solidarity mechanism is will also
work for search and rescue cases
search and rescue is a responsibility
for
on their the member states or the
coastal states
of course and saving
lives is of course always essential
and always our obligation but we must
also make sure that when
persons that have been saved at search
and rescue
and saved at sea are being disembarked
in the european union they are being
disembarked in the european union
not only in a member state and that's
why we need
this solidarity showing that also
other member states must help with uh
the relocation of people that being
disembarked uh through
search and rescue or in other ways
supporting
their member state where they are being
disembarked
i will end with what's also important
here
is that we should have more
predictability
and i think today in college uh one of
our colleagues
uh told the story of 13 unaccompanied
minors
coming to her uh country being relocated
from lesbos and being welcomed
and i think there is so such a huge
difference
when you have the names of those coming
when you know what flight they are
coming with
it's so much easier for a country to
welcome this
and to have a swift integration it's the
unpredictability it's much more
difficult to deal with
and this is our aim to have more of a
europeanized
system where we help each other to have
a more predictability in the system
so that we should not be we should not
be surprised
so we should deal with the situation
before they become
a crisis thank you thank you very much
commissioner
um yes the vice president wishes
if you give me the floor before the
question simply to say that i i
apologize because the film back to the
future
is a film by zamekis not not by
spielberg as i said so
maya culpa maya maxima culpa on
hollywood i'm not that strong
with that clarification i now open the
floor
to your questions at this stage we will
try to keep the questions focused
on the subject of the press conference
on the migration and asylum pact
as always please indicate in the system
by raising your hand
if you wish to ask a question i see
quite a number of them already raised
so the first question will be for david
david go ahead
thank
[Music]
[Music]
the my second question is for
commissioner johansson
um i mean if i go back to
what the commission proposed and
other actors member states and so on i
can find a lot of uh
points that are in in in this new
uh of fresh start
the malt agreement is more or less the
same of the relocation
for search and rescue system that you
are proposing
the flexible
relocation or flexible solidarity is the
same of the effective solidarity
proposed by the
slovak presidency in 2016.
i can go on with the new migration
partnership framework
for the third countries proposed in june
2016
with the incentive and this incentive to
readmit
migrants uh even the border procedure
that you are announcing
i can see a lot of elements that were
should have been applied in moria and
the greek
greek island because turkey was
considered a safe country so
what is really new in your proposal
thank you
thank you david mr president okay let me
start on
on maurya and lesbos
when the fire occurred in lesbos in
morya
which was of course a tragedy we were
oddly enough in a rather virtuous path
because arrivals were very low
or non-existent and with the help of the
hellenic authorities and our partners
and member states we have managed to
bring down the overall population from
25
000 to around 12
12 000 when the fire broke out
and we had also managed to relocate and
accompany miners
practical of them the 400 final ones
came out after the fire so
probably one should not underestimate
that a lot of work has been done
already there before the fire
and of course uh uh always the the the
good is the enemy of the beta
and there may things may have been done
differently
and the implementation of the utility
agreement would have been faster
but still even if all this had happened
that would have never changed the
fundamental which is maurya
is a symptom of a system that is a
non-system
it's something that is there because
precisely
there is nothing else to prevent it from
being there
and this something else is what we are
doing today
the overall amount of eu support
to greece is 2.5 not only to moria
not only on lesbos and i think it's an
argument now that is
verging on the fake news we never
paid 2.5 billion for lesvos this is the
overall envelope
including all reception centers in the
whole country
including subsidies for rent
for thousands of migrants so i would
plead
not to oversimplify on issues that are
so delicate
and so polarizing i would also make a
call
for a more sober approach
and one should not forget of it that we
still have
around more than 400 people on lesvos
people from aso people from europol
people from frontex i saw them i met
them i was there
they are dedicated european civil
servants doing the best they can
to help a very difficult situation and
the task force that the college
announced today
is precisely yet another attempt to
europeanize the management of uh
this very difficult situation in a way
that helps both the cost
the the refugee population and migrants
the local authorities
and and the national authorities now
ilda will reply to you on what is new
but let me tell you how surprised i am
that in less than an hour you managed to
digest 10 legislative texts and come to
the conclusions that there is nothing
new
and everything is reheated i i always
admire
your approach to things but this is
well commenting now this is this is new
this is really new and i know
and i have suffered it for many years
that in this city
and in this bubble there is what
i would like to call an intellectual
appeal of pessimism
that if in brussels you are a pessimist
it somehow it's okay
it's people deal with you like you
you trend i am of the school
of the intellectual appeal of optimism
and i think that it's our duty
to emit a signal of optimism today with
this new beginning
thank you uh i will answer to your
question
you are wrong these are not these old
building blocks into the new ones we are
all of the building blocks that we have
in this proposal
are new ones it's not the border
procedures are not linked to safe
countries
the malta declaration is not in there
but there is a solidarity towards search
and rescue cases and disavocation
uh the the solidarity have some
flexibility but it's not totally
flexible
it's mandatory to show solidarity and
you can choose between
return sponsorship and relocation
but you also write in one way because
managing migration
is not rocket science it's been doing
that dealt built all the time and for
all
times but what the thing is that what
not managing migration well enough
in the european union and that's because
we are lacking
the common approach and the common uh
balanced
uh legislation and this is really what's
new here
that this is a balanced approach and i
guess that we will have 27 member states
that none of them are satisfied with our
proposal
but i think that we would have said 27
member states
and parliament that will say it's worth
working on this
it's a balanced proposal and this is new
thank you very much commissioner um i
will now give the floor to stefan
stefan are you there can you hear us
stefan i understand that your mic source
is not
selected in the right way stefan
can you connect are you on the line
it doesn't seem to be the case so i will
i will revert to you later and i will
now give the floor to atanasius
hoping that he is available
absolutely i am available thanks very
much
could you please give us three practical
examples of solidarity
under the free scenario like uh
the christ scenario the uh uh expected
load scenario and normality what would
be solidarity
in practical terms from the uh member
state stalwarts who feel the pressure
three practical examples second
how are you going to improve i did not
read all the legislative proposals but
how are you going to improve the
accountability of the use of funds
that are connecting these proposals and
thirdly since we have a
teleconference of the president of
underlying with
the president of turkey erdogan tonight
are they going to talk about the
migration pact as well
in that video conference thanks
yeah i'll start with the first order
solidarity the main blocks in the solid
our solidarity mechanism are two you can
choose between
relocating those that are uh probably
in need of international protection or
you can
do the return sponsorship of those that
have a return decision
this is how member states help a member
state that
is under pressure because they have
more migrants than i can deal with in a
situation
that could be in a crisis then it has to
go quicker
and be a bit sharper and that could be
for a pressure situation
where you have a little bit more time to
work with this
of course depending on the situation and
for the search and rescue cases
we're also looking into other
possibilities
to show solidarity so it's even a little
bit more flexible
on your question on on turkey uh
the commissioner and i uh took uh uh
office
on monday the second if of december if
i'm not mistaken i don't think i am
wednesday uh the fourth we were in
athens
after the first college meeting and
thursday the fifth we were in ankara
and we did that because we
at the time as it is the case now we are
pretty sure
that the european union will
absolutely need a solid
working functional operational framework
cooperation with turkey with all our
neighbors as i was referring to earlier
but turkey in particular
and the 2016 eu turkey statement
which navigated through very turbulent
waters
and run through difficulties of
implementation
at the end of the day provided that
framework
and it's in our mutual interest even in
turbulent times
not to lose the perspective of a
cooperation of effective cooperation
with turkey this is our belief this is
our will
this is the college line
and we are hopeful that in this
process of de-escalation of tensions in
eastern mediterranean
migration will again be a part
of the positive agenda no need to remind
you that
only last summer we paid
more than 500 million euros to turkey
precisely to continue uh cooperating on
this
on this road thank you very much as to
your most specific question about the
video conference planned between the
president from the lion and
president erdogan this afternoon it will
cover like always in discussions between
between leaders all matters of joint
interest
i would be very happy to provide you a
readout following the video conference
for more details
christian
a
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
yes first on returns uh what
the european union we have a readmission
agreements with 24 countries
not all of them work but many of them
works actually
and i think that to be better to work
have better
agreements with third countries we
should do that in cooperation with third
countries
and in partnership and finding win-win
situation
and this is really what i'm doing right
now together with you the open line and
for african countries together with
oliver valley with the neighboring
countries
and where i was in mauritania last week
that we are discussed these things that
was in tunisia last
month also to discussing these things so
this is really what we are doing
but so i don't think that we should
threatening
countries i think it's better to find
partnership but we have a new
legislation that came into force
in february this this year about visa
decisions
and that makes that the european
commission
will make reports for all countries
on how well they cooperate on
readmission and returns
and that can have an implication on
whether they should have a positive or a
negative
effect on the visa
visa regulation that we have with that
country
so this is also what already is here and
i'm really looking forward to start
using this new uh legislation
the search of rescue will there be more
no they will not
not according to our proposal it will be
the opposite i guess
what we see now especially in the
central med a lot of people that are
coming there
are not refugees and if they are being
disembarked
and immediately go through a screening
process and a border procedure
and they will have the return decision
very quickly
and they will be returned i think this
will also help to people
to think twice before paying a lot of
money to the smugglers
and before risking their lives going
into these very
dangerous uh boats i don't i don't think
so
but it's also important that we should
not that would have a better cooperation
when we deal with search and rescue and
that's why we're also putting on the
table a recommendation
where the commission will help
coordinating these efforts that are
being taken by the member state
states of course but also of the private
vessel the ngos
and together with international
organizations so that we should have a
better predictability
for the disembarkations for example
thank you
okay on on dublin uh christian
i would again suggest and we have time
for a more thorough look at the
documents because uh
actually one has to read through the new
approach to comprehend
uh the difficulty the difference between
the the previous
one what i can tell you is of course
uh i i said it in my statement
that what we are doing is we are putting
dublin to bed and we start afresh
with a new much broader framework
and i would say if you allow me the
uh the self-congratulatory tone a
smarter
approach what we are doing now
is enlarging the criteria
and we are creating a hierarchy of
criteria which is new
so the country of first entry is not
the top and only consideration is part
of this hierarchy criteria
and is at the bottom of this hierarchy
criteria
as the commissioner said we are
enlarging the scope
and we have first what is the best
interest
of the child second family reunification
three visas four academic qualifications
and five country first entry and on the
family reunifications
we also open up the definition to
include
siblings so this shows
that dublin okay
we can still discuss if you want to put
it in bed or put it inside or leave it
behind
but what we are having here is something
totally new
totally different thank you um
now i would like to give the floor to
griselda
i hope you are on the line griselda
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much i will now give the
floor to francisca who's the next on my
list
francisca are you on the line
francisco can you hear us are you there
this doesn't seem to be the case this
doesn't seem to be the case hello can
you just
please go ahead yes please go ahead
thank you very much
um i have one question for commissioner
johansson
um you spoke about the um pre-screening
or the water control that should
happen for every asylum seeker and i
would like to know you said it's only
five days that it should last how do you
want to ensure that it's only
five days and will it be under the
responsibility of the national state
where
um they are or under the eu and then you
also mentioned the accelerated asylum
procedure for
some applicants um that should be up to
12 weeks i would like to know where
should all these people stay then
at that time because i mean 12 weeks
three
months will there be more camps than
built on the islands in greece and on
the island italy
because i mean friends should they sleep
in tents like i don't know what do you
foresee and how do you want to make it
possible that really it's done in this
time because
at the moment it's not happening
we should have to know more camps like
moria
i think that's very obvious what we need
is swifter and more efficient
procedures so the screening procedure
will take
place at the border and this
responsibility for the member state
to do that but of course uh the european
agencies are also happy to help
and to be that to support and i think
five days should be enough
to do their fingerprints the the health
checks
and the security checks and to take the
decision on what kind of procedures that
should be
then for the border procedures it should
ideally take
place near the borders but we are not
that stiff in our proposal
it's also possible to have somewhere
else for the practical reasons
and i think that 12 weeks is a quite
a quick process and that's what we'd
like to have
because i think this is one of the
shortcomings today
that a lot of migrants are left in limbo
without decision and i think this is not
good for the individual
and for sure not good for our european
system or for societies
you should have the your decision and if
you're coming from a country with a very
low recognition rate
i should say that that will be uh not
the most difficult
uh issues to deal with of course you
have to go through an individual process
for that and then you will have the
decision and then you will have your
return decision
and i'm quite sure that this will lead
to the situation
where those that know that they will not
have the right to asylum
actually think twice or even more time
before
they enter irregular to the european
union and that's
actually the aim because today
two-thirds
of those come into european union will
have a negative
asylum decision but many of them stays
for years
in our union without really having the
right to stay here and this
is not acceptable this is what we have
to deal with you commissioner allow me
to
um also remind journalists that we will
also have a technical briefing following
this um
press conference so you can have you can
ask many detailed questions there as
well with our
uh with our knowledgeable experts i will
now give the floor to
victor the next on my list victor are
you there
you need to press speak like always for
us to hear you
so victor ah okay sorry i hope you can
hear me now mr skinners you have talked
about the wounds caused by mandatory
quotas i would just
like to clarify things is there in your
proposal
in any part of it some kind of mandatory
quota so let's say under
extraordinary circuit circumstances
where there are hundreds of thousands of
uh migrants or asylum seekers refugees
coming to europe is there any possible
scenario where there would be
mandatory quota imposed on a state that
it doesn't agree to it and if so how
would you convince
anti-migration leaders such as victor
orban andre babish and others
to agree with your package and not to
use this
this part as a weapon to say simply no
as they have been
saying so far thank you very much
i may answer that there is no
mandatory quotas for relocation
in no circumstances in our proposal
but there could be quotas but then you
can choose between
relocation and return sponsorship
thank you i will now uh
yes the question on uh how we convince
leaders okay how can we convince
leaders first of all i think that
one if one takes a closer uh
look and um and with some
cool headness of what we're putting on
the table today
i think
he or she should recognize that
our start is different we are doing
things
anew we have a new fresh beginning
bringing together everything that we
think
matters to everybody else in a way that
the overall equilibrium is attained
because if we would have given the full
maximum of everybody's expectation then
that would be a non-starter everybody
knows
that you cannot reconcile the maximum of
expectations so
we hope that this capital of trust
that we are starting building today will
be recognized
across the geography of the european
union
we had a very encouraging uh meeting
today this morning in the college with
ilva
where we were very encouraged
from the unanimous support of our
colleagues representing different
sensitivities political geographic and
others
and we very much hope that in the days
and the weeks that follow
everybody will make an effort to
take a more positive
look of what we're trying to do here and
we also hope that when we enter into the
legislative process
both legislators will be able to
concentrate on what
unites not on what polarizes
and if this process works then i'm
confident
that we can have a second big historic
agreement for a europe that delivers
after last july's agreement on the
recovery package
thank you very much the next one on my
list is alexandra
so alexandra you hope i hope that you
are connected
and you can check the floor
yes hello do you hear me yes all good go
ahead
yes okay a question regarding the crisis
mechanism of the pact
do you have a specific threshold in mind
for when member states can trigger the
mechanism
and is it or is it up to the member
state to decide
and also follow up to attanasia's
question if i may where do you exactly
see the role of turkey in this proposed
fact
especially when it comes to the returns
a member state can ask to activate the
crisis or the pressure situation is the
commission who assess
whether this is the the case or not
yes and just to complement this
point we are talking about the crisis
we're talking about
a high threshold 2015 type of situation
now on turkey as i was saying earlier
if there is something that can be part
of the positive agenda
between eu and turkey other than the
areas identified in the 2016
agreement is this renewed emphasis
on our bilateral cooperation in the
light
of the proposal we're tabling today why
because the 2016 proposal was yet
another piece
of a of a very fragmented situation
now everybody can see that the european
union
is preparing at last a single
policy framework for immigration and
asylum
and this certainty predictability as the
commissioner said
is not something that matters to us but
it matters also to our partners
so in such a system i'm confident that
with turkey
not only with turkey but especially with
turkey we can continue uh working
together
and we should never forget that turkey
continues to host
to host millions of syrian refugees
a commendable work uh as it is the case
also for
jordan and lebanon under often very
difficult circumstances
thank you very much the next question
goes to
thomas thomas are you there can you hear
us
trying again you need to select your mic
source i'm told
because we can't hear you and we can't
see you for the moment
yes do you hear me no yes all good go
ahead
thank you very much can the countries
that have an issue of rule of law with
the european commission
offer to sponsor returns and
if a country accept this sponsorship is
it relieved from
any uh responsibility uh vis-a-vis the
persons that are returned
and let me briefly say that i was
surprised that you criticized
journalists for not having read the
papers that were published few minutes
before the beginning of this press uh
conferences it's true that we tend to be
sometimes
pessimistic and pessimism is not always
good but
enthusiastic journalists they tend to
live in countries where i'm sure that
neither you or me
i want to leave thank you very much
uh yes with the return uh sponsorship
uh it works like if a member states to
take responsibility
to return a specific uh these 100
people from a specific country then they
take over the responsibility for those
and of course the same kind of
regulation
and rights and rules apply whether
there's a new member states or the
original member state that is
responsible the the principle unknown
full moon for example is of course there
and all all these have to be carried out
in a way so that the country that should
accept them
can they identify you will issue the
travel
documents and then you're also
responsible for the reintegration
measures in the country of origin the
actual flight
can be carried out by frontex but the
other measures can only be carried out
by another member state and i think this
is really
to address the issues that we have today
we have a lot of people that are coming
here
that have to be returned and this is an
important part of showing solidarity
helping each other on doing these
returns and i should also say we are
stepping
out in other aspects i will appoint a
return coordinator
we will also set up a network of
national
experts on returns we will have a better
expertise on returns from front text
so we will help member state to do these
returns
of course in line with fundamental
rights
hugh the next question will be
for james james are you there
yes hello i'm here here let me just uh
quickly return to thank you very much uh
for the question
um i just have a practical question
about how a return sponsorship would
work
i mean presumably these returns would be
taking place from countries like italy
and greece
but being somehow overseen by countries
such as hungary and poland
so be interested in in how exactly that
would work and
there are elements of this proposal
which do seem to carry
echoes of the visa grad groups 2016
proposal
for flexible solidarity i just wondered
how much influence
did those proposals have on these please
oh sorry no we are not influenced by
those who don't want to take
relocation but we have dialogue with all
member states
and we are taking into account the
shortcomings
of today and one of the big shortcomings
of today
is that we're not good enough on carry
out returns
and i think that's why while we are
having so much emphasis on returns in
our proposal in many aspects
occluding into the solidarity mechanism
and to see those countries that today
are under the biggest pressure with the
biggest
amount of migrants that that is
cyprus number one malta number two
small countries and they have a lot of
people there
that already got a negative asylum
decision
and i should say that could be actually
of great help
if they would have some help of doing
the returns of these people
and on the uh how exactly return will
function i think we just answer also to
the previous question for
uh being complete the next
person on my list is thomas thomas are
you there can you hear us
yes we have thomas yes i can thank you
um i'd like to raise an issue that
hasn't been mentioned before that is
secondary
migration could you please clarify which
measures your plan foresees to
prevent and contain secondary
migration and very specifically under
the current dublin
system there is a time frame of six
months
in which a person can be brought back to
the country of first entry housed this
going to change
under your proposal thank you yeah
this it can be brought back in six
months
that's we're not going to change that
but the big thing that we do that we are
closing the loopholes
today in the current legislation it's
possible to abscond
and after 18 months turn up in another
member state
we close this and instead we have the
distribution
of the asylum applications already from
the beginning
and that includes also families formed
in transit
siblings those have been working in a
member state those have been
studying in a member state and also if
they are coming on a visa
and then apply for asylum it's the
country who issued the visa will be
responsible for deal with application
so there will be a big shift we will
have more people being distributed
to other member states and we will have
no people absconding and just turning up
that's the predictability thank you very
much
now the floor goes to lorne lorne i hope
you are there
connected i am indeed lorne cook from
the associated press
uh a question for commissioner johansen
um firstly you said there won't be any
camp on lesbos but there's obviously
going to be
a reception center can you tell me a bit
about that is that going to be
buildings or are we going to have more
tents is it going to be big you know we
had
13 000 people in in moria there for a
while i'm i'm trying to understand
how this approach is going to be
consistent with european values of
dignity
and for the vice president just can you
tell me what guarantees you can give
that the commission is actually going to
in fact enforce the rules
because there are there are rules in
place already we know they're weak
and after 2015 they were managed things
were managed in a bit of a panic
so i felt there was this reluctance to
kind of take action against member
states
we've got covert now so there's even
more reason to to step very lightly
are you ready to get back in in court
again to defend these uh reforms
first the situation in moria right now
is that everybody
has shelter intents but of course this
is not a sustainable situation
next week three thousand people will be
relocated
out of moriart or lesbos
and we need to continue doing that we
need to winterize the facilitation
and the new reception center of course
cannot be won
for 12 000 people it offshore has to be
in line with our european values and our
european standards
and that's why they commission the
college today
to the decision of appointing a special
task force
and that's going to be under my
responsibility that we together with the
greek authorities
together with other member states and
also with international organizations
will work better to use all the
resources that we have
to make sure that we can live up to the
standards that
european citizens and migrants could
expect from us
on implementation um
both of us uh when presenting this at
the college we made it clear and i think
it was understood by our colleagues that
this is not
an an analytical operation this is not
like a paper
or a thesis this is a design
this is the design of a system which is
meant
to change the situation on the ground
this is something that will make
implementation
much more
pragmatic easier if you like because we
will have
this notion of a circuit where from the
first moment that someone would arrive
at the external borders of the european
union
until the end of the circuit there are
well
defined procedures under the law with a
sufficient guarantees of efficiency
human rights compliance to
to international rules and so on and so
forth so
um implementation is much more difficult
in the system that we're having now
which
i like to call a non-system because we
have
bits and pieces that require a certain
check of implementation
but things would be much easier we
believe
and we hope into this new blueprint
now the floor goes to maria hoping that
she is on the line
maria are you there yes hello can you
hear me
yes all good go ahead hello
thank you very much um i'll do this in
french no maria
it's not voluntary to respond to the
solidarity mechanism
it's mandatory for all member states at
the end of the day
to contribute to the solidarity
mechanism and the
two main way to doing that is by
relocation
or return sponsorship and the reason why
it's put like this is that this is the
challenge we have
two thirds of those irregular irregular
arrivals
must be returned and that's why it's
important that member states also
show solidarity when it comes to return
sponsorship
so it's not that it's going to be a few
member states that will contribute all
member states
have to contribute to the solidarity
mechanism
uh yes there will also in in addition to
the new legislation of monetary
mechanisms
independent monetary mechanisms at the
borders we are also imposing that member
states should be applied
to investigate the allegation of
pushbacks
thank you i will now give the floor to
martin i hope that you are there and you
can
connect
martin you need to press the speak
button
as we used to say for us to hear you
yeah sorry about that
yes no i mean and now you've said a few
times that there will be no mandatory
quotas and it will be voluntary to
relocate or take responsibility for
returns
but i think you need to explain what
exactly happens if there is not enough
relocation offered i understand there's
a correction mechanism in the end of
that but what happens after that
correction mechanism
if there's not sufficient relocation
offered
um and then my other question is as you
know denmark has an
opt-out in the field of justice and home
of this um
will it be possible for denmark to opt
out of certain parts of this
pact or do you see the whole as one pack
meaning that denmark will have to accept
the whole thing or can just be part of
some of it thank you thank you martin i
will give the floor to commissioner i
will also remind you that we have a
technical briefing afterwards which can
clarify many of the very detailed
questions that uh that you have good
ones
detailed ones as well yeah i must say
this is
there there will be quotas but you can
choose whether you will contribute to
your quota
via relocation or return sponsorship or
a mix of those
there is no mechanism saying that you
have to do
especially relocation you can always
choose
a return sponsorship instead if you want
and that is because we need both
relocation
and return sponsorship and i for sure
think that we will also
have the both of those so we have a
corrective mechanism but that's for the
total
for relocation and return sponsorship
together
there is there are another rumors that
there is at the end of the day a
possibility where
uh there you have to take relocation
instead
of return sponsorship but that's not the
case it's not in our proposal
when it comes to denmark denmark already
have
opted out from some of these uh
parts and that will of course be the
case also
for the upcoming very much commissioner
i will now give the floor to maria
from opentv maria i hope you can hear us
are you there
hello may i ask my questions in greek
um yes the comments
translation in greek though
only the vice president
[Music]
a
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much next on my list is
nick nick the florisaurus
hello nick are you there
you need to press hi donna um hello yes
i'm here um uh hi there it was just a
quick follow-up on the
um unauthorized movements as you you
call them in the documents
um what sort of measures do you expect
individual member states to take to you
know
prevent those happening because you say
you really want to sort of
disincentivize them
and kill them off um and if this
these proposals are kind of introduced
and implemented in full
should that be the end to sort of
irregular camps in places like
northern france and and here in belgium
should someone be
able to get from southern europe say
greece
all the way up to the northern coast of
europe you know without being stopped
and
potentially sent back thank you thank
you
i think this is a very uh important uh
question that we are racing
we need to come back to a full
functioning schengen area
and that means that it should be
possible to
move freely in the schengen area and
that's why it's so important
that everybody that comes to european
union irregularly
are being registered and screened and
that we have a decision
which country is responsible for dealing
with the asylum application
if the person applies rep for asylum
otherwise it might not be possible to
come into the european union if you're
not allowed to
so that means we have a system and where
everybody should be registered and it's
easy to find with the fingerprints in
the eurodoc
registration uh who is responsible
for this person if this is an asylum
applicant
and it's also in our proposal that you
can do this
screening process also for those that
you find
on your territory even if it's not at
the border
so the answer is yes and the answer is
also i think this is necessary
to be able to come back to fully
functioning schengen area and trust
between member states
very much i will now take the last three
questions for
today um because we will also have a
technical briefing which will answer
many of your
questions i will now give the floor to
patricia patricia can you hear us
thank you thank you for the floor
um i have a question for commissioner
johnson so make sure
to elaborate a little bit more
on the solarity mechanism
in the situation of disembarkments
is the solidarity mechanism going to be
automatic and can you
please explain a little bit how it works
yes uh the answer is both yes and no
of course people that are being
disembarked if they
are being screened and someone they have
to go to a border procedure
and some of them might have a return
decision those are not going to be
relocated but the others could be uh
relocated
and of course uh then we what uh
margaret skinner's already uh
explained here we would have a
pre-committed
pool so that we do not can get away from
these ad hoc solutions
vessel by vessel so that we know in
advance
where to relocate people thank you very
much i will now give the flow to
danielle
hoping that this is possible technically
daniel are you there
i'm there can you hear me yes daniel go
ahead
um we just seen in question the
follow-up success
of the software
[Music]
um
of refugee mercy
i think i already answered this question
there is
a there is a obligation to contribute to
the solidarity at
the end of the day you have to do it via
returns
or via relocation or return sponsorship
the in our proposal there is no
situation where
all member states have to do relocation
but in our proposal
all member states have to contribute to
the solidarity mechanism
the last question goes to angela angela
i hope you are there
yes sir
there you go can you hear me okay
uh good morning thanks for the
opportunity um sorry to go back to the
same point
you are saying that the solidarity is
compulsory
but what makes solidarity compulsory
what happens to a member state
if they don't choose between relocations
or
returns thank you very much
well due respect i think the question
was answered several times including one
ten seconds ago and we can go through
all this in the technical briefing which
will follow seamlessly
thank you very much for your interest
and for your very many questions thank
you very much to the vice president to
the commissioner and
albert will now take over um to
lead the pres the technical briefing
thank you
you